Ciao a tutti ragazzi, il giorno in cui ho
aperto questo canale sapevo che questo
momento sarebbe arrivato: il mondo del
beauty si è accorto di me. Qualche settimana
fa Garnier mi ha mandato questi prodotti, uno al
carbone, l'altro all'argilla bianca che
servono per purificare la pelle e
pulirla dalle varie imperfezioni. Ora...io
ho cercato di spiegare loro che doveva
esserci stato un piccolo malinteso
perché...io sono perfetto, però loro hanno
insistito proprio e... me lo ricordo ancora la tipa
che mi fa "Dai Guglielmo sarebbe
perfetto se tu utilizzassi questo
momento per, non lo so parlare magari di
qualche tuo difetto e mandare un
messaggio che nessuno è perfetto. Tesoro
mio, sì certo guarda sarebbe stupendo
peccato che io sono pazzesco eh". Sono
l'incrocio fra Gandhi e un tronista di
Uomini e Donne, peccato che del primo abbia preso
l'aspetto e del secondo l'intelligenza. E
poi scherzi a parte non mi va di fare
l'elenco delle cose che non mi piacciono
di me...sulla confezione c'è scritto
3 in 1, detergente scrub maschera. Si
ottimisti io sono il modello avanzato
Io sono 30 in 1, tipo i giorni del mese,
o 300, come il film, con Gerard Butler, su
Sparta, quello dove alla fine muoiono
tutti e 300. Però alla fine ho deciso di
accettare, in primo luogo perché sto perdendo la
faccia, cioè proprio in senso letterale,
perdo pezzi de faccia, faccio tipo Hansel
e Gretel, che per paura di perdere la via
seminano la ghiaia. Ecco no io invece
mi perdo queste breccole di pelle in
modo da poter ritrovare la strada per
casa nel momento in cui mi perdo nel
bosco o se vi piace di più l'immaginario sono
tipo Nagini, avete presente? Faccio la muta.
Senza contare che, chiedo scusa ai più
deboli di cuore, io sono stanco ogni
mattina di mettermi davanti allo
specchio e trivellare, alla ricerca del
petrolio. A quest'ora sarei uno sceicco,
miliardario. Calcolate che sto messo così
male che ho smesso di chiamarli punti
neri, ormai li chiamo punti di sospensione,
perché se non sono in gruppo
proprio non si palesano. Io mi sveglio e
li vedo lì, queste linee tratteggiate
tipo quelle della settimana enigmistica,
non so se avete presente quelle che se
tipo le unisci alla fine esce una forma tipo di un animale
o di un oggetto, ecco io se le unisco
viene la faccia della mia estetista con
sotto scritto "Quando cazzo vieni?". Quindi
sì direi che mandarmeli non è stata
una scelta sbagliata...
maledetta! E poi mi piace questo concept
che c'è dietro questa campagna, cioè di
parlare dei propri difetti specialmente
in un'epoca in cui facciamo di tutto per
nasconderli. Pare fatto apposta ma è un
periodo nel quale veramente ho un bisogno
particolare di parlare ed è bella l'idea
di poter fare il proprio lavoro
mentre si parla di cose in cui si crede
Perciò allacciate le cinture,
mettetevi comodi perché quello che sto
per dirvi potrebbe arrivare come uno
shock...Io non sono perfetto
lo so, è difficile da credere, lo so.
Anzi a dirla tutta sono quanto di più
lontano esista della perfezione cioè,
così è esagerato, cioè non è che sono satana
però allo stesso tempo non sono
nemmeno Madre Natura di Ciao Darwin
Basti solo pensare che sto applicando
una maschera senza un cerchietto
o qualcosa per portarmi indietro i capelli,
già la dice tutta. In totale onestà sono
una persona normale, mi impegno a fare la
cosa giusta e il più delle volte mi accorgo
di farlo nel modo sbagliato. Prima che
pensiate male però sappiate che faccio
anche l'opposto, cioè faccio anche la
cosa sbagliata nel modo giusto, della
serie che peggio non se po'. Sono una persona fortunata
il che vuol dire che se c'è una sfiga di
base a mettercela sono io, faccio scelte
infantili, sono superficiale, ho una
costanza paragonabile solamente a quella
di una farfalla, che vive un solo giorno
e non si deve preoccupare la settimana
dopo di tornare in palestra. Vi dico solo
che mi hanno detto di utilizzare questi
prodotti all'interno di una routine
quotidiana per tipo avere il massimo
dell'efficacia, io alla parola routine già
avevo i tremori e vedevo una luce alla
fine del tunnel. Ma ultimamente ho avuto modo di pensare
tanto e un giorno allo specchio me lo sono
detto "Cresci cazzo ti tocca!", anzi "Cresci
cazzo ti tocca!". Basta pensare che le
persone attorno a noi siano costrette a
convivere con i nostri difetti solamente
perché "Cioè sono troppo una parte di noi"
quindi ci devi stare". No perché un
bambino che si sbrodola è tanto
simpatico e divertente, un adulto che
si sbrodola è uno spettacolo abominevole
Basta dare agli altri degli alibi per abbandonarci. Poi
perché lo facciamo? Per avere una
spiegazione al motivo perché ci
sentiamo soli? Essere imperfetti è tosta
ma è alla base di quello che siamo
Persone si allontanano, le opportunità
fanno lo stesso, neanche le parti del tuo
corpo vogliono più stare con te, ti cadono
i capelli. Con l'arrivo dell'inverno pezzi di
faccia ti si staccano e migrano per casa
tipo le rondini. Calcolate che qualche giorno fa
mi si è staccata un'unghia del piede,
così a buffo, della serie "Ciao cioè me ne
vado sono una donna indipendente, non
voglio più stare con queste altre". Io me lo
immagino poi bloccata nel calzino "E adesso
come faccio a uscire?". Sinceramente non so
che problema abbia con...coi piedi, cioè
unghie e mignolini che si vanno a
sfracellare, alluci valghi. Veramente io a
volte confondo le mie scarpe con il
contenitore dei bastoncini dello Shanghai.
Che poi non sono l'unico ad avere
problemi coi piedi, chissà perché? Boh.
Sarà che è anche grazie a loro se cammino
Il problema è che cammino anche quando
non ho assolutamente idea di dove andare
se devo fare una scelta non è che faccio
come gli adulti, cioè che mi fermo
davanti al bivio e faccio "Vediamo un
attimo cosa...ok qui c'è scritto
salvezza, ok perfetto,
vediamo un pochino cosa c'è scritto
dall'altro lato. Merda, beh direi che la scelta è
abbastanza, abbastanza ovvia. Nooo, noo
io proprio vado sparato "Ok cosa c'è, cosa c'è, leggo. Cosa c'è scritto? Merda
ok perfetto è l'anagramma di dream.
Ma è assurdo, assurdo io, assurdo così
Mi chiedo "Dai che cosa potrebbe mai succedere"
cioè dai ok sbagli ma che cos'è che ti
potrebbe mai capitare di terribile?
Al massimo si recupera se fai un piccolo
errore, no te lo dico io che cosa può succedere di
terribile. Hai presente una doccia? Ecco
immaginatela per sette giorni di fila
Hai presente questa crema? Il bagno ti ci
deve fare. Lo scrub non tre volte a
settimana, tre volte al giorno come i pasti. Ma che sto a fa?
E non parliamo dei pasti che io riesco a
essere incoerente anche in quelli eh. Avete
presente che dicono che la dieta
perfetta preveda una colazione da re, un
pranzo da principi e una cena da poveri?
Ecco io ne preferiscono un'altra. Io faccio
la dieta della guerra, praticamente
mangio come un esercito e piango come
chi si appresta a morire. Io proprio
mi ingozzo e poi me ne pento e l'unica
cosa che mi piace del digiuno è che
finisce con uno, che è anche la durata dei
giorni delle mie diete, e la cosa
divertente è che la stessa cosa la
faccio con le persone. C'è chi è bulimico
nel senso più tradizionale del termine e
chi come me è bulimico di affetti, per cui io alla fine
mi ingozzo, ingozzo, ingozzo di persone finché a
un certo punto non ce la faccio più e le
butto via e non posso più nemmeno
guardarle come....come un superalcolico dopo
che ti sei preso una sbronza. Vado avanti
come lo Yin e lo Yang e tratto la
filosofia in maniera incoerente e cerco
di fare dell'incoerenza una filosofia di
vita. Così mi trovo a percorrere binari
opposti nello stesso momento, amore e odio
verità e menzogna, divano e palestra,
voglia di barbecue e di cena vegana allo
stesso tempo. Quasi fossi un alchimista
che cerca di unire fuoco e acqua nella
speranza di trovare la pietra filosofale,
il problema è che l'unica pietra che mi
ritrovo in mano e quella pomice, che
continuo a a sfregare contro i talloni
nella speranza di eliminare i calli che
mi sono fatto a furia di percorrere la
strada sbagliata o la pietra che continuo a darmi in fronte nella speranza
di aggiustarmi il cervello come si fa
con un elettrodomestico rotto
Il problema è che a me è capitato il
frullatore, quindi quando l'attivo col
cervello ci faccio un frappè. Vi giuro
avrei fatto anche un elenco di tutte le
cose che non mi piacciono a livello
fisico, perché in teoria era quello
l'intento, e fidatevi che ne ho un sacco ma
parlando mi sono reso conto che la lista
delle cose che non mi piacciono a
livello caratteriale faceva impallidire
la prima. Così ho preferito rigirarmi
come un calzino e analizzarmi per quello
che ho dentro, che poi è quello che sono, invece che
parlare del superficiale che è quello che
mostro. Per il brufolo di turno, per
qualsiasi imperfezione, per i punti neri
voi potete trovare facilmente un alleato
ma la cosa difficile è trovare un alleato
che vi stia vicino per tutte le
imperfezioni che avete dentro. Qualcuno
che riesca a farvi sentire levigati
purificati senza macchie ne punti neri,
non tanto qui, ma qui. E la cosa
divertente è che quella persona molto
probabilmente la conoscete e la incontrate
ogni mattina anche se gonfia di sonno
davanti allo specchio, e quella persona sei te
Se quella persona non impara a
trovare un equilibrio fra quello che
mostra e quello che tiene dentro e non
impara a prendersi cura di quello che ha
dentro così come fa con quello che ha fuori
secondo me perde un pochino di
importanza preoccuparsi dei denti storti
e forse acquista più significato il
chiedersi perché non si sorride mai
E magari il vero cambiamento per il quale
dobbiamo sperare è cominciare a darci
dei motivi per farlo, ogni giorno. Ciao
Comunque posso dire che funziona ragazzi. Ti senti la pelle... porca...minchia. Mo ti tocco
E ce le ho gratis. Senti la faccia. Oddio. Madonna oh. Effettivamente...
Ce ne hai un po'? No, per te no